hi I'm Carlos so who controls the  internet the Internet is a global  collection of networks that are all  combined into one humongous integrated  network there are many organizations  that control and owned many aspects of  the Internet these include governments  corporations private citizens schools  and service providers so in fact  everyone has a little stake in the  Internet the reality is that no one body  owns at all no one owns the internet and  there is not a single person  organization that controls the Internet  in its entirety there are however  organizations that oversee and  standardize what happens on the internet  for example the National Science  Foundation funds the internet research  the internet Engineering Task Force  develop standards in use on the internet  the Internet Corporation for Assigned  Names and numbers icann coordinates IP  addresses and domain names and the world  wide web consortium which is  headquartered at MIT develop standards  used in the web